Public Sénat en partenariat avec l'AFP
les échos Radio Classique
[Musique]
présente pierre gataz le président du
meddf et l'invité de l'épreuve de vérité
bonsoir Monsieur gataz et merci d'être
avec nous en ce jour d'actualité chargé
sur le plan économique et social à ce
rendez-vous que vous propose donc bien
sûr Public Sénat en association avec les
écho radio classiques et l'Agence France
Presse trois grandes questions vous
seront posées au cours de cette émission
la première par Jean-Francis pcrè dans
un instant chômage plans sociaux est-ce
la rechute pour l'emploi à livré tout à
l'heure le dernier chiffre de 2016 très
mauvais à le nombre de demandeurs
d'employ repartis à la hausse en
décembre plus 26000 même si sur l'année
hein ce chiffre a baissé deuxème
question que vous posera Orian Mancini
Fillon Macron quel programme économique
à votre préférence enfin 3è question
brexit Trump est-ce que vous êtes
inquiet de la défiance grandissante
vis-à-vis de l'Europe également de la
mondialisation vous répondrez là à
Guillaume dadin mais d'abord monsieur
gataz une autre question d'actualité
tout de
suite une question où l'emploi est
également en cause le conseil
d'administration DDF a donc ouvert
aujourd'hui la voie à la fermeture de la
centrale de Fessenheim en acceptant
l'indemnisation proposée par le
gouvernement est-ce que vous êtes dans
le camp là des des syndicats qui sont
opposés à cette fure écoutez si c'est
une décision purement politique ou
philosophique je suis très gêné par
cette fermeture parce que on sait que le
nucléaire c'est un gros investissement
de la France depuis des décennies que
c'est une énergie décarbonée propre que
cette cette usine aurait pu encore
fonctionner je crois pendant pendant
quelques années jusqu'à 202 l'utorité de
sé exactement donc si vous voulez si
c'est une décision politique ça me gêne
profondément si c'est une décision
rationnelle liée à une sécurité qui
pourrait être défaillante ou des des
investissements trop gros de maintenance
ce qui peut-être une bonne raison en
disant il faut démanteler à ce moment-là
je me rallie à la décision je n'ai pas
suffisamment de je l'imession vous
pensez que c'est une décision politique
quoi moi je pense que c'est une décision
malheureusement très politique et ça me
gêne en effet alors après je ne
connaisse pas le suffisamment le dossier
pour vous donner un avis circonstancier
h d'accord est-ce que vous croyez à une
reconversion du site comme le dit
aujourd'hui seolen royal qui parle d'un
choix positif pour EDF ce qui est sûr si
vous voulez c'est que dans toutes les
reconversions d'usine il faut trouver
des systèmes pour réembaucher les
personnes ça peut-être dans le cas du
nucléaire toute une filière de
démantellement de sécurité de
démentantellement d'optimisation
d'énergie renouvelable tout ce qui est
énergie climat c'est développement
durable sont des filières d'avenir donc
je pense qu'en effet si vraiment la
décision est confirmée qu'elle est
rationnelle il faut et bien continuer
bien évidemment de travailler sur la sur
l'emploi et idéalement local d'acord si
la décision est rationnelle mais vous
nous avez dit que vous pensez plutôt à
une décision politique voulu par
François Hollande il veut il veut
remplir cette promesse avant de quitter
le pouvoir écoutez si si c'est ça bon
après regardons comment ce cette
décision ou cette prédécision évolue
dans temps d'accord justement alors s'il
y a une décision politique pour essayer
de précipiter la fermeture vous espérez
un revirement en cas d'alternance
politique moi je crois qu'il faut
regarder ce dossier encore une fois je
connais pas en profondeur il faut
regarder le coût le coût de la
maintenance pourquoi on le ferme
exactement si on est fait cette cette
filiale est trop vieille et le coût de
de la la prolonger coûterait une fortune
le coût il a déjà été engagé il y a eu
des travaux importants qui ont été
engagés sur cette centrale de festhe ces
dernières années oui alors après je ne
sais
pas alors d'accord y a la mise au norme
et puis ensuite il y a l'exploitation
par année bon soit c'est rationnel et
voilà soit c'est pas rationnel si c'est
politique ça me gêne on d'accord si
c'est politique ça vous gêne et vous
dites aux politiques que le nucléaire
est un atout pour l'économie française
oui fondamentalement c'est un atout ce
sont des investissements énormes que
nous avons fait c'est c'est une c'est
une énergie propre décarboné maintenant
lorsqu'on a fait l'investissement c'est
quand même idot de le supprimer vous
considérez que par exemple le nucléaire
aujourd'hui 75 % de la production
électrique ça vous va très bien comme
pourcentage mais je crois qu'il faut
évoluer vers un mixte je pense que si
voulez il faut pas être tout nucléaire
non plus il faut en effet arriver sur
les énergies renouvelables
sur en investissant sur ce enfin en
capitalisant sur ces gros
investissements que nous avons fait
depuis 30 ou 40 ans question d'actualité
suite maintenant pierre gataz avec
Jean-Francis P qui nous rejoint le
directeur de de la rédaction de Radio
Classique bonsoir Jean-Francis bonsoir
Michel bonsoir
pierre les chiffres du chômage pour le
mois de décembre ont été publiés euh ce
soir plus 26100 chômeurs en catégorie A
est-ce que c'est la
rechute je dirais que euh c'est une
situation très fragile parce que la
France n'a pas fait toutes les réformes
qu'il faut faire
par contre ce que nous voyons c'est que
sur un an l'économie française a créé
plus de 100000 emplois ce qui est quand
même une bonne nouvelle sur la période
ça veut dire que le PACT de
responsabilité que nous avons c'est
100000 chômeurs 100000 de moins 100000
chômeurs de moins 180000 emplois en plus
alors 100000 chômeur de moins ça veut
dire qu'il y a eu la création de
l'emploi quand même de l'économie
française à recréé de l'emploi c'est ça
alors pas suffisamment puisque vous
savez que vous avez des jeunes qui
arrivent sur le sur le sur le marché à
hauteur de 120 130 140000 donc en effet
ce n'est pas suffisant 100000 en créé
par an c'est bien parce que ça montre
que le pacte de responsabilité lorsqu'on
baisse les charges ça fonctionne mais
vous savez que pour vraiment baisser le
chômage c'est ce que nous disons depuis
des années c'est une multimédication ou
c'est plutôt des multivitamines qu'il
faut donner à l'économie française je
vais vous donner un petit exemple quand
je demande à mes chîn entreprises que je
vois sur le terrain toutes les semaines
pourquoi vous créez pas d'emploi
première raison il y a ceux qui me
disent j'ai pas les marges pierre je
n'ai pas les marges il faut continuer je
ne peux pas investir je ne peux pas
innover je ne peux pas exporter ça c'est
la première raison deuxième raison je
trouve ceux qui se disent moi je
pourrais embaucher mais j'ai peur j'ai
trop peur donc voyez bien qu'il y a
aussi le problème de la peur d'embaucher
qui reste constant chez les cré chez les
créateurs de richesse que sont les che
entreprises trème je vais aller très
vite trè trè raison j'ai les marges j'ai
pas peur d'embaucher en France mais
c'est trop compliqué pour étendre mon
bâtiment mon usine mon trop compliqué la
complexité la bureaucratie elle est
énorme en France il faut régler ce
problème là pour que soit tout soit plus
simple et 4ème raison et dernière raison
ouais ça sera la dernière c'est
important parce que si vous voulez
qu'andon écoute les che entreprisees on
est on on peut mettre des réformes en
face de ça la 4e raison c'est tous ceux
qui disent je pourrais tout faire tout
ça mais je ne trouve pas les emplois je
ne trouve pas les compétences dans
l'industrie on cherche des soudeurs des
chaudronniers des mécaniciens on cherche
des webmasters dans les services on
cherche d'autres popations environ
300000 emplois demandés par an non
pourvu et là vous retrouvez sur les
quatre problèmes de la France pour
recréer de l'emploi si on met quatre
réformes en face et bien vous pouvez
vraiment espérer baisser le chômage
ouais
on a le sentiment quand même que vous en
voulez toujours plus vous avez eu 40
milliards de baisses de charg de baisse
de charge sur le quinena 41 milliard
pour être exact on a l'impression que ça
ne va jamais assez loin si vous voulez
c'est pas c'est pas ça c'est après une
montagne de 35 milliards de charges
qu'on a pris sur la figure vous savez il
faut regarder les chiffres précisément
c'est un problème de Marg les marges
c'est 32 % en France elles sont
reconstitué les marges ell sont
sononstitué de 4 points nous som passé
de 28 % à 32 la moyenne européenne est à
40 39 40 vous avez encore 8 points c'est
quoi ben c'est la fiscalité qui en
France a continuellement augmenté cette
fiscalité est liée à quoi aux dépenses
publiques de fonctionnement qui vous le
savez atteint des sommets on est sans
doute les champions de l'Europe de ça
c'est 57 % du PIB en dépenses public
donc si vous voulez tant qu'on ne
règlera pas ça avec courage et ambition
c'est-à-dire la baisse des dépenses
publiques de fonctionnement et bien nous
ne pourrons pas baisser la fiscalité ni
sur les entreprises ni sur les ménages
et et vousz situation mais c'est pas ça
attendez la faute moi je prends mes
responsabilités qu'est-ce que je fais je
parle du numérique je vais j'emmène les
PME à l'exportation je les emmène en
Afrique je les emmène en Asie je
travaille sur numérique je fais des
outils de sensibilisation sur le
numérique je parle d'innovation je parle
de management je parle de parlité je
forme des jeunes des quartiers à
l'entrepreneuriat je suis dans l'action
complète et jeattends pas tout du
gouvernement alors après moi je demande
que chacun ait sa responsabilité moi je
m'occupe d'innovation de management de
motivation d'enthousiasme d'essayer de
booster l'entrepreneuriat je demande à
ceux qui nous gouvernent et bien de
régler les problèmes qui sont dans leurs
compét c'est-à-dire de nous faire un
environnement économique salariés de
vivarté qui ont appris aujourd'hui qu'il
y aurait 700 emplois en moins dans le
groupe que la marque André va être vendu
que la marque Nafnaf va être va être
également vendue et que la Hal aux
chaussures près de 200 boutiques vont
devoir fermer dans les dans les toutes
prochaines semaines et que ce groupe a
aurait perçu 16 millions d'euros de
crédit d'impôt compétitif et emploi
qu'est-ce que vous leur dites mais je
leur dis si vous voulez que j'ai de
l'empathie pour eux bien évidemment
parce que un plan social de 50 de 100 de
600 c'est toujours un drame local et
pour ses salariés par après je je dis
l'ensemble des Français c'est que nous
devons viser le plein emploi
c'est-à-dire quoi ça veut dire que nous
devons faire en sorte que les sociétés
puissent s'adapter en permanence car le
problème de vivarté je ne connais pas le
dossier par cœur mais c'est un un
business model qui est en train de
bouger vous savez bien qu'il vendent des
chaussures dans le monde entier et que
ce business model est en train d'être
subir la révolution numérique il faut
écouter les syndicats des
actionnation trop gourmands parce que
c'est une société qui a été reprise avec
une création de dett
excessive et des actionnaires qui sont
accusés de se nourrir sur sur la bê
est-ce que c'est une accusation que vous
entendez quandême ce sont les fameux LBO
qui permettent de racheter des
entreprises avec un effet de levier sur
la dette il y a des salariés qui
utilisent ça il y a des gens des des des
personnes physiques et puis vous avez
tous les excès tous les excès sont à
banir je ne connais pas la situation de
ce LBO de liberté ce que je peux vous
dire si vous voulez que c'est qu'ils
sont dans un business model qui doit
être bouger c'est une adaptation et je
crois qu'en effet ça va continuer
malheureusement dans le sens que le vrai
problème pour régler ce genre de chose
c'est que les gens puissent trouver de
de l'emploi rapidement c'est que si nous
étions sur un marché du travail où il y
aurait 5 % de chômage comme en Suisse
qui est à 3 % ou à Londres vous rendez
compte que ces gens-là ce serait pas un
drame parce que ils savent que ils
pourraient repartir très vite auu
management patronal assez humain sur ce
dossier là quatre patrons en 5 ans et
des salariés qui apprennent au fond ces
informations au comptegoutûte qui qui
savent que les magasins ferment qui ne
savent pas combien qui sa pas moi je
crois si vous voulez que nous sommes
tous dans un monde qui bouge à toute
vitesse dans toutes les entreprises
c'est vrai pour pour les che
d'entreprisees qui sont instables et qui
sont confrontés à une des inconnus et
c'est vrai aussi pour nos salariés c'est
pour ça si vous voulez que ce marché du
travail doit bouger permettre à des gens
de créer leur entreprise rapidement de
créer de l'emploi rapidement de
s'adapter en permanence ce que je dis
c'est qu'en effet c'est très triste de
voir des plans sociaux comme ça mais
malheureusement quelles sont les
solutions c'est vous contraignez encore
vous interdisez encore et là vous allez
vous retrouver en effet avec des
sociétés qui vont plus pouvoir s'adapter
donc les les Ch entreprises
n'emboucheront encore moins et vous
aurez un tau de chômage qui va donc la
solution c'est l'employabilité tout le
long de la vie il faut que nos salariés
nos collaborateurs comprennent qu'ils
auront peut-être 3 4 5 6 métiers 3 4 5 6
7 entreprises qui seront peut-être auto
entrepreneur ou entrepreneur à un moment
de leur vie il faut le laisser
l'économie française cette agilité
sadaptation et et en effet
l'employabilité permettra de recréer de
l'emploi face à ces drames à propos de
certaines logiques financières ou des
actionnaires évoqué Jean-Francis ceux du
CAC40 ont reçu l'an dernier près de 56
milliards d'euros écoutez ce que
dénoncait ici même à votre place la
semaine dernière le secrétaire national
du PCF Pierre
Laurent les entreprise du CAC 40 ont
distribué aux actionnaires 56 milliards
d'euros en
2016 niveau record ils ont retrouvé le
niveau d'avant la crise financière de
2008 alors qu'on m'explique comment
c'est possible que les dividendes
continuent d'exploser mais qu'il n'y a
jamais d'argent pour mener des
politiques sociales pour augmenter les
salaires mais si vous voulez dans toutes
les entreprises de France j'en ai une on
passe notre temps à tenter de motiver à
augmenter l'intéressement à faire que
les gens soient heureux motivés épanouis
employabl vous avez en effet des cas
vous avez whpool vous avez vivart vous
avez des cas d'adaptation avec des plans
sociaux mais il y a beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup d'entreprises qui sont gérées
de façon normale mais en dans
l'adaptation euh bon et donc ce que je
dis c'est que les dividendes mais ne ne
les dividendes c'est leur rémunération
du risque nous avons besoin
d'actionnaires dans tous les pays du
monde l'économie de marché l'entreprise
fonctionne avec des clients fonctionne
avec des sous-traitants des fournisseurs
fonctionne avec des hommes et des femmes
et avec des actionnaire donc je dirais
que déjà la le dividende est normal
alors après est-ce qu'on est-ce qui est
excessif en France sur le C 40 je ne
sais pas je sais que le CAC40 en effet
sont très internationaux ont des fonds
de pension qui demandent des
rentabilités dont l'État qui est pas le
celui qui en demande moins et et après
en effet la fiscalité française fait que
comme elle est très dure sur les
dividendes parmi les plus dures en
Europe en en flux et en stock et bien il
y a peut-être une une une distribution
plus forte pour compenser une fiscalité
plus dure après si vous voulez voilà je
pense que ce il faut arrêter de
diaboliser les dividendes les dividendes
servent à financer l'économie ça marche
dans tous les pays du monde comme ça et
et je crois que il faut pas s'en
offusquer alors après en effet il y a
des dérives il y a des excès qu'il faut
condamner je ne sais pas si 56 milliards
c'est un excès pour la France la toute
dernière usine française de World poool
qui a été rachetée par un italien qui
s'appelle Indesit va être délocalisé à
lots c'est en Pologne est-ce que vous ne
craignez pas une fois encore que le
marché européens que les règles
européennes soient mis en cause et qu'au
fond ce les les salariés Damien soit
victime d'une forme de dumping européen
de dumping social moi ce que je vais
vous dire c'est que nous sommes dans un
monde de transformation la France a des
atouts exceptionnels extraordinaires
dans plein de filières d'excellence dans
l'aéronautique dans la santé dans le
tourisme dans l'industrie 4.0 dans le
numérique formidable dans plein
d'activités nous sommes des champions
dans beaucoup de filières il faut
accepter mais pas dans le cchelinge mais
non mais dans ces chelinge soit ils
auraient pu trouver alors une idée comme
la SEB de mettre de l'Internet de mettre
de l'électronique de changer de et de
faire du premium mais euh moi je ne
crois pas au low cost fabriqué en France
oou alors il faut être très très fort
avec des homutates comme Bic euh qui
fait du du low cost mais premium low
cost avec des automates je crois dans
France soit il faut accepter je dirais
de se transformer alors le problème
qu'on a sur amamien c'est de nouveau un
bassin d'emploi qui est touché donc nous
travaillons sur le MF au MF sur vous le
savez nous sommes à 4 mois d'une
élection majeur pour la France nous
travaillons sur des doctrines des
propositions sur par plus tard et et je
pense que sur les territoires il faut
absolument continuer non pas de bloquer
des adaptations qui sont nécessaires
mais de recréer de l'entrepreneuriat de
l'emploi mais là c'est pas une
adaptation là c'est une purge
l'entreprise
F de son label Origine France oui alors
après de nouveau si vous voulez soit ils
ont la possibilité de rebondir de et
cetera soit il dit c'est pas possible
j'espère qu'il y a eu tout un processus
pour dire on va adapter on va s'adapter
on va mais vous savez vous êtes des
révolu il faut que l'État puisse puisse
accompagner les les salar écoutez vous
avez bien sûr quand on peut accompagner
mais pour pour garder de l'emploi mais
après si vous l'ingérence de l'État ça
conduit parfois un plan social encore
plus horrible 1 an ou 2 ans après donc
moi ce que je dis c'est qu'il faut
s'adapter en permanence il faut que les
chef entreprises français et
investisseurs étrangers et il faut
surtout améliorer l'attractivité de la
France l'attractivité de la France c'est
de faire en sorte que no nos charges
baissent et qu'il y ait une convergence
sur le plan des charges au niveau
européen et de la fiscalité et sur le
plan social ça prendra peut-être 5 ou 10
ans mais il faut travailler sur cette
convergence pierre gatata je voudrais
votre sentiment sur la situation de
l'économie française et sur son avenir
dans les euh au cours de l'année 2010 17
201 les quelques années à venir est-ce
que vous avez le sentiment quand vous
voyez que la croissance repart doucement
de manière extrêmement lente que les
investissements ne sont pas tout à fait
au rendez-vous que nous continuons de
perdre des parts de marché en Europe
est-ce que vous avez le sentiment que ça
patine toujours oui ça patine toujours
pourquoi parce que les réformes onont
pas été prises et lorsque j'entends
certains débats des candidats politiques
où il y a une résignation on Nura plus
de croissance et on pourra plus créer
d'emplois en France euh moi je suis
estomaqué c'est absurde c'est un
programme de résignation total la
croissance il faut aller la chercher moi
je la vois partout la croissance je la
vois en Afrique l'Afrique demande que
les Français reviennent faire des
infrastructures je la vois en Europe il
faut un projet européen je la vois en
Asie je la vois dans le numérique je la
vois dans le tourisme la croissance on
faut pas se résunir en France à avoir 1
% de croissance c'est faux on peut avoir
durablement au-delà de 2 % je vais
essayer de le prouver avec mes études au
niveau du MF ça c'est la première chose
deuxièmement l'emploi il y en a de
partout potentiellement sauf que si les
ceux qui peuvent créer de l'emploi les
chînes entreprises il y a queeux qui
peuvent créer de la richesse de la
croissance et de l'emploi qu'on leur
pose leur problème pourquoi vous créz
pas de problè et parce qu'ils ont peur
parce que c'est trop compliqué et cetera
donc si vous avez un chef d'État qui
arrive en mai et qui dira moi je fais
confiance au chef d'entreprise je leur
fais confiance 1 c'est très important
deuxièmement voilà les quatre réformes
que je vais faire et ben je peux vous
dire que les Ch entreprise
toute taille repartiront vers
l'exportation vers le numérique aura de
nouveau un renouveau de la France qui a
tous les atout pour réussir on sait déjà
on sait déjà ce que certains candidats à
la présidentielle nous disent vous allez
pouvoir juger leur programme dans un
instant merci beaucoup puisque c'est
maintenantan manchini de Public Sénat
qui arrive pour la deè partie de
l'épreuve de vérité monsieur
[Musique]
gataz bonsoir votre question donc à
notre invité très désireux de parler des
programmes des candidats et de son
propre programme d'ailleurs aussi j'ai
cru bonsoir pierre gataz bonsoir entre
Emmanuel Macron et François Fillon quel
est celui qui a le programme économique
qui vous séduit le plus il y a pas un
problème de séduction il y a un problème
de détail le problème de François Fillon
est détaillé il est pragmatique c'est le
plus complet aujourd'hui sur le plan
économique je m'exprime je ne vois pas
grand-chose de la part d'Emmanuel Macron
je vois des quelques phrases quelques
brides de propositions mais je ne vois
pas de programme complet et pas la
cohérence donc
j'attends encore de voir si Emmanuel
Macron arrivera sur un programme
détaillé notamment sur le plan
économique alors le programme de
François Fillon il est cert détaillé
mais vous l'avez critiqué notamment sur
sa la suppression des 500000
fonctionnaire alors justement est-ce que
vous maintenez cette critique non c'est
pas sinon est-ce que vous pouvez nous
expliquer ce que vous avez V dire vous
avez dit là il va mettre le le feu au
pays des fonctionnaires quel est quel
est le problème quel est le problème il
faut fondamentalement que tous les
candidats part parlent des dépenses
publiques et de la réduction des
dépenses publiques ça c'est ça c'est
fondamental pour baisser la fiscalité
redonner des marges et de l'oxygène aux
entreprises il faut le faire nous avons
plein d'idées pour le faire et on peut
le faire avec les fonctionnaires
directement c'est ça que j'ai voulu dire
c'est que c'est très bien d'annoncer un
objectif c'est formidable il faut le
faire et bravo il l'annoncé bravo Mo
500000 mais non je dis pas bravo moin
500000 je dis bravo de dire il faut
réduire les dépenses publiques alors
après que ça fasse 100000 200000 500000
700000 on verra alors après pour réduire
comme dans nos entreprises qu'est-ce que
nous faisons lorsque nous avons des
adaptations à faire et bien nous le
faisons avec les fonctionnaires
eux-mêmes mon seul propos sur sur cette
conférence de presse c'était de dire
500000 fonctionnaires il faut expliquer
comment on fait et il faut le faire avec
les fonctionnaires pourquoi je dis ça
parce que quand vous interviewz des
infirmières des médecins dans les
hôpitaux notamment ils disent mais nous
on voit plein de problèmes plein de
dysfonctionnement et on n'arrive pas à
le remonter à la hiérarchie vous demand
à franisillon de revenir sur sa
proposition 500000 fonctionnair mais non
là vous avez pas compris non je dis
qu'il faut mais non il faut c'est une
problème d'exécution et de méthode quand
vous êtes dans une entreprise vous
prenez une décision qu'est-ce que vous
faites vous l'expliquez cette décision
c'est un problème de méthode et pas de
c'est un problème de méthode c'est un
problème de méthode mais pourquoi parce
que il faut que ça passe cette méthode
il faut expliquer comment on va faire
mais pas de brutalité parce que je pense
c'est le conseil à François mais mais
c'est pas un conseil je me permra pas
une in j'ai juste vécu la loi et
comomerie version 1 de janvier qu'est-ce
que j'ai vu j'ai vu une loi qui é allé
plutôt dans dans le bon sens en janvier
qu'on a appelé la version 1 et puis j'ai
vu qu'elle était pas comprise pas
expliquée qu'elle était brutale on a eu
la version 2 la version 3 la version 5
la version 6 bon où il reste presque
plus rien donc moi ce que je dis c'est
que au niveau où est la France et on a
vu depuis des années si on a pas de
projet enthousiasment d'abord pour le
pays pour les Français une France qui
gagne et qui fait gagner tous les
Français nous travaillons là-dessus au
niveau du menf depuis des mois
deuxièmement c'est pour le plein emploi
c'est pas pour autre chose restons sur
les propositions quand même Paris
revenir à mais mais je reviens donc je
pense que si vous voulez il faut
expliquer euh clairement le pourquoi des
choses le sens de ces réformes et et si
poss alors vos propos monsur pour éviter
on est fait un rejet brutal vos propos
ont été perçus comme le disait Orian
comme une critique par les fillonistes
écoutez Bernard accoyet le secrétaire
général des républicains vous lui
répondrez j'appelle monsieur gataz à
lire le programme de François Fillon
manifestement un il l'a pas lu
correctement de il n'en a pas compris
l'esprit deuxièmement j'entends toujours
monsieur gataz se plaindre de l'excès de
dépenses
publique le candidat qui veut l'a
diminué la ramené à un niveau juste
normal il le critique si Monsieur Gatas
ne lit pas bien le programme et fait des
déclarations qui me paraissent tout à
fait déplacé d'ailleurs il s'agit pas de
supprimer les fonctionnaires je m'élève
contre cette formule c'est la réduction
du nombre de poste d'emploi public mais
c'est très bien il faut faire de la
pédagogie comme il vient de le faire
dans sa dernière phrase bravo formidable
parce que pourquoi je vais vous dire on
me dit mais c'est pas ton problème
l'exécution la méthode je si c'est notre
problème de chez entreprise qui sont
ceux qui souffrent qui sont ceux qui
sont victimes des des des politiques
lorsqu'il y a 3 millions de personnes
dans la vue des grèves dans tous les
sens les S peuvent pas venir vous
désorganisz vous enlevez des des des
points de croissance qui sait qui à qui
on on augmente les contraintes des
obligations c'est encore l'chelle
d'entreprise donc je dirais nous sommes
nous subissons parfois malheureusement
des manques d'explications donc nous
souhaitons en effet ce programme
économique de France fr Fillon nous
paraî détaillé nous paraî pragmatique
nous paraî courageux nous paraî
courageux ce qu'il faut juste c'est que
on l'explique mieux plusation plus de
pédagie éviter le syndrome de la loi
elcomerie de janvier 2016 que
j'ailiquerah c'est plus compliqué est
vrai que suite à cette déclaration
pierre g vous avvez envoyé un SMS à
François F pour vous excuser mais oui
parce que si vous voulez vous
savez c'est une explication si vous
voulez pour er exp qu'en effet moi je
suis juste sur la méthode et encore une
fois dans nos entreprises nous nous
faisons du management toute la journée
d'adaptation nous sommes en adaptation
perpétuel dans nos entreprises la France
a besoin d'une adaptation donc moi ce
que je dis mais très humblement c'est
que il faut le faire avec les gens avec
les français pour ça c'est montrer une
vision positive de la France à 5 10 ans
on peut F faire on a les atouts on peut
faire 2 % de croissance on peut revenir
au plein emploi et ensuite comment on
fait le partager le faire avec les
compatriotes et sur la fonction publique
en effet je pense que en encore une fois
ce n'est pas une leçon c'est une un
conseil c'est une recommandation c'est
c'est ma façon de voir je pense qu'il
faut associer les gens aux adaptations
vous allez le rencontrer François Fillon
pour lui dire tout ça mais oui mais je
lui ai déjà dit ils le savent parce que
c'est ma méthode depuis 4 ans et c'est
comme ça que j'ai géré ma société
radiale depuis 25 ans et figurez-vous
que ma société rayale j'ai gardé quatre
usines en France et une 5è que j'ai créé
parce que j'ai associé meses mes
salariés aux idées à la résolution des
problèmes ça s'appelle de l'IM
management s'appelle du management
s'appelle de la motivation ça s'appelle
et vous associez les gens et les gens
sont heureux et sont fiers de participer
au succès et bien c'est comme ça que
dans un marché composants électronique
extrêmement difficile et compétitif j'ai
gardé 5 usines en France sur 9 et on
exporte 90 % de notre ch d'affaires
c'est tout et et je pense que c'est une
question de méthode et d'explication
c'est tout vous avez rencontré Pierre
Gatas Gérard larch qui est la caution
sociale de François Fillon que vous
êtes-vous
dit j'ai rappelé tout ça
j'ai la Mée on a parlé de cette méthode
j'ai dit en effet que il y a quatre
réformes fondamentales à faire que la
France est dans une situation historique
un moment historique où elle patine et
si en mai juin il se passe pas les
bonnes choses on va continuer de
décrocher ça serait quoi les mauvaises
choses les mauvaises choses c'est que
les réformes ne se fassent pas non non
mais attendez sur le plan électoral mais
écoutez que bah des gens je dirais ne ne
ne donne pas la confiance au chef
d'entreprise ne suscite pas la confiance
la confiance c'est 50 % du business
c'est 50 % de la croissance pour les
ménages c'est pareil vous avez confiance
vous consommez un chef entreprise il
fait pas la grève qui vous fait le plus
peur il fait pas la grve un ch
d'entreprise qui vous fait le plus peur
parmi les candidats là c'est pas une
question de peur c'est une question de
cohérence de programme économique ben si
vous voulez moi je
qui si vous voulez dans ce monde de 2016
d'une économie ouverte globalisée
euh moi je crois que la croissance il
faut aller la chercher he de le plein
emploi
estce que vous allez vous engager dans
la Cagne est-ce que vous allez prendre
position pour ou Candat j'aimerais que
les candidats parlent de croissance à à
générer j'aimerais que les candidats
disent on peut pe aller au plein emploi
j'aimerais que les candidats disent les
seuls qui peuvent créer de la croissance
et de l'emploi c'est l'entreprise
l'entreprise c'est la clé de tout et
j'aimerais que les candidats de gauche
et de droite pour éviter de donner des
noms n dis ça est-ce que vous allezager
est-ce que vous allez vous positionner
clairement la France est une formule
est-ce que vous allez vous avez entendu
la
question on va se positionner je ne me
positionnerai pas je l'ai déjà dit je ne
prendrai pas position par contre je vais
continuer de regarder les programmes
économiques je peux vous dire que le
plus détaillé aujourd'hui le plus
pragmatique c'est celui de François
Fillon que j'attends beaucoup d'Emmanuel
Macron parce que je n'ai rien ou presque
rien aujourd'hui pourcoup vous attendez
parce que vous avez beaucoup d'espoir
aussi mais parce que il est pas encore
sorti donc voilà si et vous avez dit que
ce qui dit est tout à fait intéressant
mais c'est intéressant sur le sur
l'aspect vous connaissez la personnalité
Macron il y a des g des gens qui aiment
il a des gens qui qui aime moins voilà
après c'est des questions de personne
mais sur le programme en tant que tel
pour jug mais non écoutez c'est un
problèmec si vous vous souvenez il était
venu dire j'aime l'entreprise lors de
votre université r ça c'est Manuel Val
qui est venu qui dire j'aime
l'entreprise lui aussi ils disent la
même chose pour le coup effectivement
le mais il faut pas faut pas faut être
précis si on parle d'une présidence de
la République française dans une
situation où la France est en train de
décrocher doucement mais sûrement et
qu'il faut il faut faire des réformes
solides rationnelles pragmatiqu autour
de l'économie autour de l'entreprise si
on veut régler le problème du chômage et
un d'autres choses redonner l'espoir aux
Français et bien c'est par l'emploi
l'emploi c'est l'entreprise donc c'est
tout ceux qui parlent de l'entreprise
j'espère qu'ils en parlent comme ça et
en effet ça fonctionnera ceux qui n'en
parlent pas du tout ou si c'est
uniquement pour dire on va au
contraindre on va augmenter les impôts
on va augmenter les dépenses et bien ça
non je suis désolé parce que là vous
allez vous retrouver avec un taux de
chômage immense et des che entreprise
qui vont être complètement démotivé
justement de ces candidats à l'élection
présidentielle vous allez recevoir
pierre Gatas quand écoutez il est prévu
qu'on fasse des des matinées avec les
dizaine ou la douzaine de candidats
majeurs je dirais et ceux idéalement qui
auront eu leur investiture en fait leur
leur signature il a dates pr je pense
que sera à partir du 15 mars 12 mars 15
mars jusqu'au 15 avril est-ce que pour
vous il y il y a une ligne rouge à ne
pas franchir quand vous les quand vous
les entendez comme celle notamment de
laisser filer les déficit ce qu'on
entend chez beaucoup de candidats mais
oui il faut écoutez on est arrivé trop
loin c la sphère la sphère publique est
obèse en France et ceux qui portent
cette sphère publique c'est les
entreprises donc il faut réduire ces
sphères publi et il faut le faire avec
avec beaucoup d'explications et quand
vous entendez après vous avez autre
chose je reviens sur mes quatre réformes
vous avez donc la fiscalité améliorer
pour augmentter les marges d' entreprise
je j'appelle que la croissance il faut
aller la chercher pour aller la chercher
ça veut dire exporter ça veut dire
investir ça veut dire s'automatiser ça
veut dire embaucher tout ça vous avez
besoin de Marg si vous n'avez pas les
marges vous pouvez pas le faire et
deuxième grand bloc le social il faut
faire en sorte de déverrouillé ce marché
du travail qui est encore très anxiogène
et après il faut faire du marketing de
la France car qu'est-ce que vous dit les
étrangers qu'il soitent chinois japonais
américains j'étais encore avec eux ce
matin vous savez les Français bah
doucement vous décrochez vous êtes pas
attractif donc il faut rendre la France
attractive pour que des jeunes talents
indiens chinois américains viennent en
France pour que des investisseurs
viennent en France tout ça ben il faut
réformer la fiscalité on sait exactement
ce qu'il faut faire et le marché du
travail alors vous avez cité les
responsables politiques qui ont dit
j'aime l'entreprise François Fillon
Emmanuel Macron bien sûr manuel Vals
encore hier soir n'est-ce pas Orian vous
n'avez pas cité Benoît pourtant c'est
lui qui a le V en poup chez les
électeurs socialistes et lui il annonce
la fin du travail et il propose un
revenu
universelangez dans quelle catégorie la
catégorie des programmes absurdes
absurde et idéologue pourquoi parce que
le constat qu'il fait c'est il y a plus
de croissance et il y a plus d'emploi
c'est fou la croissance encore une fois
il faut aller la cher March dans les
entreprises moi j'ai passé 7 ans à
essayer de trouver Boeing sans avec une
rentabilité faible en investissant avec
des ingénieurs et ben je l'ai fait et
ben maintenant ça va beaucoup mieux j'ai
j'ai généré de la croissance pour mon
entreprise et ben un pays il faut aller
générer de la croissance on sait où elle
est et deuxièmement l'emploi et bien je
peux vous dire qu'on peut descendre à 5
ou 6 % de chômage pourquoi en libérant
les talents lib libérant les énergies
alors après si vous voulez en effet beno
Hamont et beaucoup plus sur il y a plus
de travail les robots donc il veut taxer
tout il veut tout taxer les robot non a
pas ça enlever les 40 milliards du PCT
de responsabilité allons-y et puis je
sais pas comment il va faire donc si
vous VZ c'est une économie totalement
administrée idéalement pour lui je crois
sans entreprise ce sera encore mieux
donc si vous voulez là je suis très
angoissé enfin angoissé dans le sens sur
le le plan irréalisme de de du programme
qui qui n'existe pas sur le plan
économique c'est juste de dépenser plus
et c'est de de taxer encore plus tout ce
qu'on peut euh alors que c'est
exactement robot vous seriez un gros
contributeur hein chez chez radial mais
les robots si vous voulez il faut savoir
il faut il faut savoir les robots euh là
encore si vous des gens qui ont pas mis
les pieds dans une entreprise qui ont
géré jamais géré des entreprises ont des
ont des concepts incroyables les robots
les Japonais les les Allemands les
Suédois ont beaucoup de robots
énormément de robots ça leur permet de
faire de l'excellence opérationnelle et
donc de trouver de la croissance de
prendre desps de marché et ben ce sont
des pays qui sont très automatisés très
robotisés qui ont des taux de chômage
faibles le reven universel un mot
absurde aussi pour vous he pire éc mais
mais écoutez tout
tout tout salaire mérite travail je
dirais que par et le revenu DESC proposé
par Manuel valz qui lui fait le lien
avec le travail et l'insertion ça vous
convient mais que temporairement on est
des gens en transition entre deux
emplois bien évidemment à à se former à
retrouver un travail c'est fondamental
mais dire aux jeunes aupulation reven
DESC vous pourriez dire oui mais le
revenu descend temporaire et je dirais
bord ce qu'il faut c'est tendre vers le
travail c'est remettre les gens dans le
travail toutes dernière question non
mais j'insiste là-dessus c'est
fondamental c'est une philosophie mais
le travail pourquoi parce c'est
l'épanouissement de l'homme c'est la
fierté de l'homme le le travail on le on
le on le Bafou depuis des années en
France les peuples émigrent vers
l'Europe notamment et vers parce que il
cherche du travail donc le travail c'est
essentiel faut arrêter de dire Pierre
Laurent qu'on a entendu tout à l'heure
promet de mobilisation dans la rue après
la présidentielle quel que soit le
résultat pour peser est-ce que vous
cinez un troème tour social c'est pour
ça que je dis partageons une vision
d'une France vertueuse partageonsla
largement l'importance de l'entreprise
écoutons ceux qui peuvent créer de la
richesse et de l'emploi vous avez un
pays formidable avec des atouts
extraordinaires qu la France vraiment
extraordinaire on a une chance inouï
cultivons cette chance développons ces
fiier d'excellence et ce qui me rend
optimiste c'est que vous avez 60 % de
jeunes aujourd'hui qui veulent être
entrepreneurs et ça c'est extraordinaire
et que les les citoyens Français mettent
l'institution PME en tête des
institutions les plus crédibles ça veut
dire que la France est en train de
basculer vers un pragmatisme un bon sens
ah donc vous ne créez plus les grandes
manifestations de rue écoutez je pense
qu'il faut faire beaucoup d'expcation
question je reviens sur la pédag merci
beaucoupan trè partie de l'émission
maintenant avec Guillaume dadin de la FP
qui nous rejoint pour vous poser une
question monsieur gataz très bien les
preuve de vérité avec lafp bonsoir
Guillaume bonsoir bonsoir monsieur gataz
a eu le brexit en juin l'élection Donald
Trump il est président depuis quelques
jours vous êtes inquiet vous du du rejet
croissant grandissant contre l'Union
européenne la
mondialisation oui je suis inquiet je
suis inquiet parce que la mialisation
c'est une chance en tout cas pour la
France et je le prouve tous les jours
par ma société radiale qui exporte 90 %
de sa production donc je dirais que ce
recroqueviller sur nous-même c'est une
très mauvaise solution beaucoup de
filières d'excellence française
d'entreprises françaises exportent c'est
elles qui réussissent le mieux
d'ailleurs donc si on commence à avoir
un syndrome je ferme les frontières je
le vois aux États-Unis et ce serait ça
pourrait donner des bonnes idées en
France non la mondiation c'est
l'ouverture c'est l'opportunité de
croissance alors après si vous voulez ce
que je reçois comme signal faible quelqu
part du brexit et de Trump c'est vous
avez deux populations vous avez ceux qui
sont dans les métropoles qui profitent
de l'exportation de la croissance du
numérique tout va bien et ceux qui sont
dans les régions dans les territoires
qui sont souvent oubliés ou dé V moi je
crois si vous voulez alors c'est une des
raisons et je crois qu'il faut faire
attention en France c'est pour ça que au
MF nous travaillons aussi actuellement
ardemment pour dire il faut pas qu' les
métropoles d'un côté avec la croissance
et puis des tas de territoires déserté
donc nous cherchons des moyens pour
garder de l'emploi
les pr surtout parce que les garder
artificiellement ça marche pas vous êtes
rattrapé un jour ou l'autre par la
patrouille donc il faut il faut avec les
moyens numériques le haut débit
numérique avec le télétravail avec
l'entrepreneuriat de susciter des
créations d'entreprises des commerces
qui peuvent donc dans toutes ces régions
un peu déserté en France où il y a des
taux de chômage élevé je pense que on
peut trouver des choses des moyens quand
quand quand Donald Trump fait des tweets
et parle de Ford de General motor c'est
que Ford du coup plus ou moins
directement suite à ses tweets décide de
de garder une usine aux États-Unis et de
ne pas la faire au Mexique vous
applaudissez du coup vous parlez de
l'emploi local qui reste si vous voulez
bon après c'est le c'est les États-Unis
et c'est la méthode de Monsieur Trump
tant mieux s'il arrive à faire c'est une
méthode que certains réclament en France
aussi par exemple à mondbour il était un
peu sur cette ligne là il d'ailleurs il
s'est comparé à Trump non mais attendez
qu' cultive le patriotisme économique
français moi je dis bravo oui il faut le
faire le problème qu'on a c'est que
c'est la méthode encore une fois c'est
vous pouvez le faire par la contrainte
par lois par la réglementation et là
vous êtes foutu parce que là vous faites
fire tout le monde tous les
investisseurs et vous pouvez le faire
par par les valeurs par l'incitation par
par le patriotisme que vous pouvez
développer moi encore une fois ma
fierté vous dirait le résultat
l'important c'est les emplois qui
restent aux États-Unis oui oui mais si
vous voulez si vous vous recroquevillez
sur vous-même et que vous êtes dans un
protectionnisme exacerbé vous rendez
compte que le monde est quand même
extrêmement ouvert un avion comme le
Boeing est fait de mes composant
électronique d'ailleurs mais tous les
composants viennent du monde entier donc
je ne sais pas si vous voulez peut-être
que sur une usine particulière où il y a
un choix en train de se faire bah il
pousse un peu en disant ce serait mieux
que vous la mettiez aux États-Unis bon
pourquoi pas et si ça s'il y a du s'il y
a en face une baisse de charge et de
fiscalité ça peut se concevoir sur un
sur un programme économique après si
vous voulez si vous recquvillez
complètement et bien je pense qu'il y
aura a pas tellement une baisse de
charge comp en face il y a surtout une
perspective de hausse de la fiscalité
surtout
impô c'est quelque chose que vous il a
parlé de de baisse massive d'impôts il a
parlé de 75 % de réglementation en moins
c'est genre de discours que vous
pourriez peut-être oui mais le danger si
vous voulez le danger c'est qu'en effet
son protectionnisme peut aller très très
loin qu'il qu'il augmente les droits de
douane dans beaucoup de filières et se
retrouve et moi je pense que ça ne
fonctionnera pas je pense aussi et je
pense aussi que les lobbyes de ces
entreprises n'accepteront pas ça on va
l'écouter Donald Trump il n'a que le mot
américain à la bouche c'est suivront
deux règles simples acheter américains
et recruter
américains voilà il a annoncé quand même
oui non mais si vous voulez vous savez
de GA il y a un moment parlait de France
de France France France France et cetera
alors après encore une fois la méthode
vous pouvez le faire par la contrainte
en faisant fuire tout le monde par les
lois par les textes par la complexité et
puis vous pouvez le faire par le cœur
bon après si vous voulez c'est la
première puissance économique au monde
moi je pense qu'en effet si il est trop
extrême et on verra comment ça se passe
euh je pense que c'est très inquiétant
pour l'économie mondiale pour le marché
mondial pour les flux commerciaux
mondials euh et alors ça nous
aiguillonne au niveau de la France pour
faire que l'Europe se développe et se
reconstruise le plus rapidement possible
avec une France dont l'économie se
ressaisisse le plus vite possible parce
que l'Europe aujourd'hui c'est juste
l'Allemagne l'économie qui fonctionne
bien correctement c'est la emagne
l'Europe ne fonctionne que sur parler
mais il y a tout un tas d'accords
commerciaux internationaux de libre
échange qu'il est en train de de
d'envoyer à la cheminée il y a le le
traité de libre échange transpacifique
il a annoncé hier que 8 ans de
négociation tomb à l'eau il y a le le
ttip le traité entre l'Union européenne
et les États-Unis il veut renégocier le
traité de libre échange nord-américain
ça ça peut peut-être vous inquiéter
justement mais mais je mais si vous
voulez je suis inquiet par ce genre de
de chos de déclarations suivie de Signat
et cetera très très médiatisé en effet
quel monde on veut est-ce que c'est un
monde où tout le monde va se
recroogviller je pense que que la
première puissance économique au monde
est un réflexe de de se recocvier sur
sur elle-même me semble très dangereux
pour l'économie du monde mais aprs c'est
un vrai basculement quand même de
paradigme il est plus seulement dans
l'incantation c'est c'estit il agit mais
après si c'est pas aussi simple que ça
parce que vous avez des processus vous
savez qu'il y a quand même le CMA la
chambre et cetera donc il y aura
peut-être des signatures qu' pourra
prendre tout seul et puis beaucoup
d'autres décision qui passeront par un C
nombre de de d'institution et
heureusement après si vous voulez ce que
je dis c'est que ça doit nous motiver
encore plus plus vite pour faire les
réformes en France économiques qui qu'on
demande fiscalité sociale simplification
éducation il y en a quatre blocs qu'on
va décrire dans un document qui va
sortir dans 15 jours et deuxièmement
pour que cette économie française
retrouve des couleurs de la force et
pour que ensemble avec les Allemands
nous puissions faire revivre le projet
européen et ensuite je dirais que les
l'Afrique est équipé l'Afrique a besoin
de nous a besoin et le la France est un
pays qui est euh qui est qui est
prioritaire sur l'Afrique je dirais par
son par son histoire et vous toute
l'Asie donc si les États-Unis pendant un
certain temps se referment un peu sur
ellemême ce sera de très très mauvaise
nouvell parce qu'encore une fois je ne
sais pas s'il pourra refermer ce grand
continent qui a été mondialisé où tous
les flux sont sont globalisés sont
mondialisés je vous viens de vous parler
de Boeing et de l'assemblage d'un Boeing
donc je sais pas s'il pourra aller
jusqu'au bout de de ses pensées après je
pense que c'est un aiguillon très fort
pour aller vite sur les réformes
françaises pour créer l'Europe de demain
alors question oui est-ce que au final
il ne fait pas la même chose que que
souhaite Marine Le Pen en France si on
peut faire un comparatif c'est-à-dire le
libéralisme à l'intérieur des frontières
est-ce que c'est pas comme ça que vous
l'analyseriez mais si vous voulez quand
vous êtes la première puissance
économique au monde avec 300 millions ou
350 million d'habitants bon vous vous
dites je peux me suffire à moi-même et
je crois pas en plus donc il peut avoir
un rêve de le faire comme ça et en
France en France 60 60 millions
d'habitants 6e puissance au Monde je
dirais j'espère qu'on va pas descendre
trop vite non on peut pas vivre en
autarciie c'est pas possible le c'est ce
que dit Marine Le Pen elle dit on va
faire des droits de Douine on va essayer
on va essayer de recréer des industries
françaises mais si vous voulez sortons
sortons par le haut il faut recréer des
industries françaises absolument il faut
recréer des fillères d'excellence
française il faut redonner confiance à
tous les ingénieurs les chercheurs tous
les salariés les collaborateurs ils ont
des projets il y a de tout à faire dans
le monde le monde est à équiper le le
futur est à construire vous pouvez le
faire à partir de France donc libérons
ces talents c'est pas encore une fois en
sortant de la zone euro ou de l'euro
c'est pas en je dirais en augmentant les
droits de douane à nos frontières que on
fera ça alors on a vu que vous l'avez
invité à vos débats pour la
présidentielle Marine Le Pen exactement
oui comme j'ai invité Monsieur Mélenchon
alors je les ai invité pour quelle
raison parce ça ser tout juste petite
question Nathalie au Philippe Poutou non
mais je pense si vous voulez que on
invitera encore une fois les candidats
majeur je peux pas inviter les 15 ou 20
candidats d'abord ce sera filtré par
ceux qui ont les signatures autour du du
15 mars je crois qu'on aura des
informations ensuite l'idée c'est de
questionner C ces candidats Marine Le
Pen c'est un peu nouveau pour le medf on
a vu des critiques de de la personne qui
était avant vous Laurence Pariso oui
mais si vous voulez vous pouvez recul de
vos valeurs des valeurs c'est ce qu'elle
a dit c'est pas un recul des valeurs
c'est de questionner des candidats qu'il
soi d'extrême gauche ou d'extrême droite
donc moi je fais un Parel entre Madame
Le Pen et Monsieur Mélenchon d'ailleurs
les programmes économiques lorsqu'ils
existent sont très proches on se referme
sur nous-même on taxe beaucoup de chos
on sort de l'euro on rajoute des
contraintes dans tous les sens on met
des contreparties dans tous les sens dit
qu'elle veut baisser les impôts des
sociétés dit qu'elle veut
pay j'aimerais la questionner comme
j'aimerais questionner Monsieur
Mélenchon sur son programme économique
vous les invitez tous les deux je les
invite dans vous CZ pas une partie du
patronat le petit patronat où il y a
quand même pas mal de supporters de
Marine Le Pen dit-on c'est son poids
politique qui vous vous avez des gens
qui votent je sais pas quelles sont les
estimations entre 20 et 30
% et et je trouve que c'est intéress son
de questionner pour démonter pour
démonter le programme économique de ces
de de ces partis extrêmes qui qui qui
c'est plus tellement questionnement
alors c'est un questionnement puisqueen
fait il y aura trois che entreprisees
qui devrait les questionner pendant une
heure c'est ça l'idée c'est qu'on
comprenne qu'onose les bonnes questions
com
commentner peut-être mais c'est pas
questionner c'est que une fois que vous
avez que vous avez des réponses elles
sont bonnes ben elles sont bonnes si
elles sont mauvaise et moi ce que j'ai
vu depuis quelques années aussi bien du
programme de Monsieur Mélenchon que du
progamme dead Marine Le Pen c'est qu'on
revient VI sur les folies du programme
commun de la gauche de 81 c'est le SMIC
à 60 ans comm moi j'adore c'est qui va
payer comment on paye c'est augmenter le
SMIC bravo formidable mais qui va payer
comment on paye la compétitivité de la
France comment on fait si vous voulez
c'est du pragmatis la sortie de l'euro
ça vous paraît être une ligne rouge
sortie deeuro si vous voulez bien
évidemment vous vous retrouvez avec une
dette libellée en Euro et si vous sortez
de l'euro et que vous êtes en franc
français vous avez une une dette en
euros qui va prendre 20 à 30 % alors ça
c'est un raisonnement simple c'est plus
compliqu
ig je qu'il faut vis l'excellence comme
dans notentreprise la France a tous les
atouts pour viser l'excellence être
compétitive dans le monde en libérant
les talents les énergies en faisant
confiance au chefentreprise aujourd'hui
il y a pas la confiance des ch depuis
des années il y a qure blocs de réformes
fondamental que tous les pays du monde
qui réussiss ont fait c'est c'est très
simple fa vous invitez Marine Le Pen
pour tenter de l'affaiblir pour la pour
la question
je
parrecom deur Mélenchon et celui de MAME
Le Pen vous mettez dans le même sac les
programmes de jeanluc mélenchonine Le
Pen et j'ai envie de dire ben vous
l'avez critiqu écoutez j'attends
justement d'en savoir plus à l'occasion
de ces de ces rencontres voilà d'accord
alors outre Manche il y a brexit qui est
en cours le cataclysme qui était parfois
annoncé ne s pas produit non plus c'est
pas quelque chose qui pour aller dans le
sens de Marine Le Pen écoutez là c'est
les signaux faibles il faut il faut
prendre en compte le brexit c'est une
très mauvaise nouvelle pour l'Europe
après est-ce que la France pourra
profiter de de de place financières qui
pourrait venir à Paris vous revenez sur
attractivité de la France il y a une
opportunité fantastique pour la France
de récupérer des filières
d'excellence mondial de de les blanc les
banques bienvenu à Paris merci Pierre
gataz merci beaucoup Guillaume merci à
tous bonsoir à très vite à la semaine
prochaine
[Musique]